Not only do I totally understand,
I 1,000,000% appreciate it,
because
I don't like hearing advice that just affirms what I already wanna do.
I definitely put myself out there for advice,
to hear opposing ideas,
what other people have to say,
what other people have to feel,
you know, other people's opinions.
You know, I know that I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
You know,
I know that I have four children,
I pay child support,
I don't have a ton of help.
I don't in real life,
you know, like, day to day.
And I've had a relationship with a person that I trust,
like, trust, trust.
Like, there have been enough moments to,
you know, where I thought,
oh, boy, where's this gonna go?
And I'm always surprised at the outcome.
So I feel as safe as possible doing this.
Obviously there is risk when you're moving in with a person,
when you have children,
when, I mean,
just anything.
There's risk associated with everything.
And so I have thought of every possible thing that could go wrong.
Him and I have had as many open,
honest fucking conversations about everything. Money,
what happens if one of us loses our job?
What happens? Blah, ABC.
And so I think I.
I mean, I understand all the risk and the concern,
because I would have the same for a friend.
Um.
And I appreciate it.
I love it. I don't.
You know, I don't.
I'm not Ever gonna be mad
that somebody cares enough to give me their honest opinion
when it may seem a little bit hard to do that?
So I love you so much.
Thank you. Thank you for the love,
the advice, the encouragement,
the support. I am listening.
I don't want anybody to think I'm like,
no, I'm listening.
And it is in my mind.
I do genuinely feel like this is the right direction.
And I am open to wherever the universe leads or wherever my path leads.
So I will keep you guys posted on the journey.
He has given notice to his landlord.
I gave notice to my landlord.
I told my roommate I'm gonna start packing soon.
So, you know,
I don't know. I'll keep you posted.
And I am very much open to hearing opposing opinions,
and I very much value them and appreciate them,
cause I know that can be hard. So thank you.